ein thema wurde bereits angeschnitten
das ist der Klimawandel und da haben sie
Herr Jänicke ein Buch geschrieben da
sind auch Vorschläge drin wie wir den
bekämpfen können und sie sagen wir
müssen ganz klar weg davon massenhaft
Fleisch zu essen es ist ihr Thema ich
glaube es gibt ja ein paar ganz einfache
E-Mail wie man den Hebel unbedingt CO2
Ausstoß tatsächlich reduzieren könnte
vorhin schon erwähnt ein Tempolimit eine
Verkehrswende mir öffentlich-rechtliche
Verkehr ähm das ist eine Hebung der 2
Hebel sollte Fleisch und so
funktionieren Milliarden schwer Fleisch
das ist ja Mehrwertsteuer faktisch
befreit und anstatt gesunde Lebensmittel
die sehr viel weniger Energie
verbrauchen weniger CO2 verbrauchen
weniger Wasser verbrauchen wie
Hülsenfrüchte Obst Gemüse sind ja voll
besteuert völliger Quatsch also müssten
Fleisch eigentlich zum sonntagspart also
wer wirklich
abfallen einmal die Woche richtig tolles
schönes Deck von einer Anständigkeit in
Kuh und einem anständig halten so damit
könnten wir leben auch was CO2 betrifft
und ich habe darüber ein Buch gemacht
habe seitdem ein unfassbaren Lobby am
Start klar das ist in die Stadt die
wissen auch dass ihr Geschäftsmodell
halt langsam ausläuft der Fleischkonsum
geht kontinuierlich zurück nicht nur in
Deutschland der Milchkonsum geht
kontinuierlich zurück es geben immer
mehr kleine Bauern auf was ich ein
Jammer finde ist überleben nur noch groß
Konzerne und vor allem der
Rohstofflieferant ich meine das war die
schrecklich für theoretisch aber der
leidet ja eigentlich und die sind
wahnsinnigen Preisdruck den die
Lebensmittelkonzerne machen und
profituren tun die verarbeiten sehr
nicht Salz also Müller Milch tönis die
sind Milliarden schwer und es geben
immer mehr kleine Unternehmen auf vor
allem diejenigen die eigentlich Tierwohl
tatsächlich praktizieren wollen auch
anständig produzieren möchten die geben
auf und das ist ja da ist im System am
Anfang fundamentaler Fehler wir reden
seit Jahrzehnt immer eine Agrarwende
Frau Künast hat sich die Zähne
ausgebissene bei sich auch diese wir
müssen mal über den die Macht der Bauern
Lobby reden und vor allem über die
subventions-politik aus Brüssel und aus
Berlin ob wir eigentlich richtig so
funktioniert für arg gesunde
Lebensmittel für uns Menschen Tierwohl
Tierschutz das wird bis heute mit den
Füßen getreten und was Nachhaltigkeit
betrifft weil der CO2 Ausstoß von
unserer ist eine Katastrophe ein also ja
ein Drittel geht auf Kosten sie das
selbst sind sie der Sonntagsbraten Typ
oder verzichten sie komplett auf Fleisch
inzwischen kein Fleisch mehr gegessen
also ich bin noch nicht von Knochen
gefallen ich sag jetzt nicht dass es
jeder machen muss meine Großmutter hat
schon aus pekunieren Gründen einmal die
Woche richtig so ein Bracken gemacht den
gab es am Sonntag den haben wir alle
gefeiert und unter der Woche gab es Pech
gehabt wir sind alle nicht verhungert
und nicht gestorben also ich glaube die
Reduktion wäre schon mal ein
Riesenfortschritt wir haben gerade
angesprochen es ist ein Thema sie waren
in einer anderen Talkshow haben über das
Thema gesprochen sie haben einen
Shitstorm kann man wirklich sagen dafür
bekommen erscheint nicht nur ein mehrere
gleich ist scheiße ein Thema zu sein wo
ganz schnell Emotionen hoch kochen wir
klären sich das ist die Frage mit
welcher Lobby du dich anlegst und die
Bauernlobby ist extrem einflussreich die
sehr gut vertreten aber sie vertritt
eben eher die industrielle
Massentierhaltung die Massenproduktion
als kleine tolle nachhaltige Bio-Bauern
und das ist also die Fleischindustrie
setzen wir halt bei 46 Milliarden Euro
um und wenn du den auf den Schlips
trittst dann wären die sich das gleiche
macht die Milchindustrie und ich habe
kürzlich ja getroffen den Hans
foldenauer den Sprecher des
Bundesverbandes deutsche Milchviehhalter
der mir der hat mich sowas von bestätigt
weil der hat mir erzählt in den
Psychiatrien ist die Prozentsatz von
Bauern die echte depressiv werden weil
sie diesen Punkt wer ist extrem hoch die
suizidragen sind extrem großes geben
immer mehr kleine Betriebe auf da läuft
etwas falsch warum kann Müller mich
Milliarden einsacken und dafür geben
kleine mich bauen auf das heißt wir
werden ja quasi getränkt sogar die
industrielle Massentierhaltung das ist
halt gegen das Tierschutzgesetz das ist
eindeutig in Deutschland sehr klar
formuliert was erlaubt ist immer mit
Tieren wird millionenfach gebrochen es
ist ungesund für den Verbraucher es gibt
Dutzende von Studien die sagen Krebs hat
auch mit Fleisch und Zoom zu tun mit
Milch
und deswegen habe ich dieses Buch
gemacht und das hat halt ein Gewissen
Gegenwind bekommen
44 Jahren
das gesündeste eigentlich ja aber Hähne
geht ganz ehrlich also ganz schwierig zu
holen das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
sie haben jetzt eben gerade wieder
Punkte behauptet die einfach nicht wahr
sind und als ich das gehört habe was in
der Talkshow gesagt damit Sky morgen das
war einfach nicht zu ertragen das muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen für mich ist das
einfach nur eine super sie wissen genau
was sie sagen sie können sich auch
entschuldigen haben sie auch gemacht und
so ein Teil ein bisschen zurückgenommen
aber eigentlich geht's nur um ihr Buch
sie wollen Ihr Buch verkaufen sie
vermarkten dass sie wissen ganz genau
hier mehr Skandal desto mehr wird das
Buch gekauft ja und dann auf die die
Landwirte aufzuziehen das sind ja nicht
die die die die die die die Landwirte
die diese Lobby haben wenn die die Lobby
halten ja dann hätten sie doch ganz
andere Preise die noch ganz andere
Preise Alter
ich komme aus
niederlandeburg ich kenne alle meine
Landwirte ich kenne die Stelle alle ich
weiß dass teilweise drei Generation
arbeiten auf dem Bauernhof weil sie
sonst finanziell gar nicht wuppen die
lieben ihre Tiere obwohl sie wissen am
Ende ist die Schlachtbank da
Entschuldigung und jetzt jetzt kommen
sie mit so einer Aussage und hauen den
richtig eine um die Ohren das ist
unmöglich nur um ihr buchen bisschen
weiter zu loben sie fahren durch die
ganze Welt fliegen sie wo andere Leute
auch schon waren und haben ihre Dokus
gemacht da fallen da haben sie ein Klima
Abdruck ohne Ende sie fliegen
öfter nach Amerika alles meine den
können sie alles machen aber bitte nicht
gegen die Landwirte das ist unsere
Niedersachsen ist übrigens
und ich kenne alle dort ja wirklich und
das Problem das größere Problem ist ja
noch oder hat sich mal mit dem
Landwirten mit den mit den Kindern die
werden gemobbt in der Schule weil die
die Kinder von von Landwirt sind und das
haben sie mir zu verursachen und
hinterher dann einfach nur zu sagen na
ja gut also war nicht so ganz so gemeint
also den Mann und und dass sie sagen
millionenfach wird gegen
tierschutzverstoßen jeden Tag völliger
ihre völliger Quatsch ist völlig egal
seit 1992 überhaupt nein das stimmt gar
nicht es gibt Magdeburger Urteil das
müssten Sie eigentlich kennen dafür
brauchen wir bestimmte Voraussetzungen
wenn die Voraussetzungen gegeben sind
ist es erlaubt Punkt klare Lüge klare
aus Antworten
Hunde bellen finde ich völlig
legitimativ
angerufen ganz ehrlich ich habe ganze
Dokus gedreht deswegen macht über
Schwein und schweine.haltung da gibt's
sowas von großartigen vorbildlichen
Leben der bei allem im Film gehabt man
kann so oder so produzieren das ist das
Thema die Frage eigentlich im Prinzip ja
war was er das mit dem Klimawandel zu
tun und der Fleischkonsum ist ein
gigantischer Treiber von CO2 Methan
Ausstoß das können wir jetzt wegrennen
oder nicht Fakt ist es wird der
Regenwald gerode für Futter so ja 60%
der deutschen Agrarfläche ist für
Futtermittelanbau reserviert anstatt für
humane Nahrungsmittel also was ist
wollen wir jetzt mal
Entschuldigung um Soja Öl zu pressen 98%
eine weltweiten Sojaproduktion weltweit
war Europa kann gar nicht ihre Tiere
alle füttern deswegen müssen wir auch
Soja importieren bevor er Regenwald war
98 Prozent ist für Tiere das ist eine
Zahl die die meisten Leute wissen 50
Prozent der gesamten weltweiten
Getreideernte ist für Tiere bestimmen
obwohl wir 800 Millionen Menschen haben
die hier heute an Unterernährung leiden
und viele dieses Jahr nicht überleben
werden und darunter dutzende Millionen
Kinder wir Beschwerden uns hier über was
für Fehler in der Politik gemacht worden
sind Bezug auf Corona und deswegen sind
wir uns glaube ich der alle einigen aber
was heute abgeht das sind Zehntel der
Weltbevölkerung Unternährung leidet und
nicht mehr überleben wird oder viele
davon dieses Jahr das können wir ändern
weil heute findet nämlich statt das 75%
zwei Drittel der weltweiten genutzten
Agrarfläche ist für den Anbau für
Tierfutter und für Weideflächen gedacht
das heißt wir haben faktisch kein
Problem dass wir zu wenig Nahrung haben
wir haben viel zu viel geschmissen auch
ein Drittel weltweit der Lebensmittel
weg aber ein Anteil der Lebensmittel
wandert eben in die Mägen der Tiere und
auf dem Weg der Proteine von dem Land
bis es dann im Steak bei uns im Körper
ankommt gehen 90 Prozent der Proteine
verloren und das müssen wir ändern
deswegen müssen wir darüber sprechen
deswegen bin ich dankbar dass du darüber
im Buch schreibst dass du ein Shitstorm
abbekommst das glaube ich sehr weil es
natürlich da geht nicht um Milliarden da
geht es um Billionen die auf Kosten der
Natur auf Kosten unser Mitmenschen
getätigt werden von äh Industrien und
Konzern die in dieser heutigen Lage eben
Tiere und Menschen ausnutzen und die
Natur ich möchte einmal reingehen können
Sie auch die Seite verstehen hier
spricht Herr Dodendorf gerade auch von
Existenzen Landwirten die versuchen
ihren Betrieb zu halten ihr seid
Generationen versuchen ein gutes Fleisch
zu produzieren können Sie verstehen wir
haben gerade gesagt seine emotionale
Diskussion das hier natürlich die
Emotionen da geht's natürlich um
Existenz für die habe ich das Buch
geschrieben wie gesagt du kannst so oder
so produzieren du kannst deine Hühner
freier laufen lassen dann kostet es eine
natürlich entsprechend Geld oder kannst
60.000 mit einer Halle sperren du kannst
ein Schwein auf 0,75 Quadratmetern
Kastenstand quälen oder du kannst frei
laufen legal legal du kannst kopieren du
kannst es ist ja fast alles verboten was
mit Ausnahmeregeln und ein deutscher
immer noch erlaubt ist die Skandinavien
ist alles längst aufgeben und Ausnahme
von Dänemark das andere Thema was hier
nicht angesprochen wird ist der
Regenwald das ist der größte CO2
speichern jedes Kind weiß das von dem
Sommer in einem Wald reinläuft wird vier
bis sechs Grad kühler als auf der freien
Wiese wir sägen diese Regenwälder für
Futter Soja und Palmöl Weg in ein aber
witzigen Tempo und reden über die
Klimakrise über die Katastrophe an der
AH an der Erft jetzt in Neuseeland ist
läuft ja Kalifornien vertrocknet andere
Ländern ab wir reden ständig über die
Klimakrise und was passiert nicht
Fleisch Produktion ist ein riesen Hebel
ich sag nicht das wäre alle aufhören
müssen wir müssen da anders produzieren
und wir müssen gewisse Konsumgüter
reduzieren das ist alles was ich sage
und mein Herz schlägt ich wohne auf
einem Dorf in Oberbayern und ich habe in
diesem Dorf einen absoluten Muster Bio
bauen da läuft alles frei herum die Kuh
die Ziege die Hühner er hat die Ziegen
nur angeschafft damit die habe ich die
nicht seine Hühner Reißen der Schlachte
die Kuh erst wenn die komplett
vorbestellt ist man kann in einem
selbstzahlautomaten seine Bio-Eier seine
bio ist kann man sich also solche
Unternehmer kenne ich und genau die
produzieren richtig es gehören nicht 33
Millionen Schweine irgendwie in
Massentierhaltung und ich wissen wie
viel Millionen werden wir weltweit die
Ernährung wirklich aussteuern also die
Länder die jetzt als Schwellenländer
noch so aussehen als ob sie erst auf dem
Sprung sind aber eigentlich schon sehr
weit sind ihre Entwicklung zum Teil
haben eine wachsende Bevölkerung
zumindest in Asien der Fall diese
Bevölkerung möchte auch gerne mal
Fleisch essen ich sag das mal das profan
mal wer ja in Ordnung na ja die Frage
ist die müssen ja erstmal dahin kommen
das heißt wenn wir jetzt hier z.B sagen
in Europa bisschen weniger und dann geht
das aber in Asien trotzdem höher ich
sehe den Regenwald
ich sehe den Regen ich will den Punkt
aufmachen mit dem Regenwald ich sehe
noch nicht dass der brasilianische
Regenwald gerettet wird wenn die
Deutschen weniger Fleisch essen dafür
die Chinesen mehr ich mache das mal sehr
profan sehr übersichtlich
sagen ja nur weil Fleisch
andere nachmachen die Frage ist die
Frage ist die Frage ist haben wir in
Deutschland genügend Freiwillige die so
leben wollen oder ist das entworfen
begrenzte Anzahl der Bevölkerung wenn
die anderen das nicht wollen werden die
gezwungen ist eine Frage die ich hier
mal aufwerfe die interessiert mich ähm
genau das Problem würden alle Menschen
auf der Welt so leben wie sie ist
Deutschland bräuchten wir drei Planeten
ich weiß das alles ich kann jede Button
von den Grünen alle schon seit über 20
Jahren haben die geführt der Punkt auf
den ich hinaus will ist wir haben eine
veränderte Situation als in den 80er
oder 90er Jahren weil jetzt viel mehr
Menschen da sind und weil viel mehr
Länder von sich auch ein gewissen
Wohlstand wie ihn die westlichen Länder
suggeriert haben wollen für jeden von
ihrer Bevölkerung haben dass zum
Beispiel die Tierindustrie für 18 je
nach Studie 18 bis 51% aller globalen
Treibhausgas verantwortlich ist es mehr
sogar in der untersten Studie mit 18%
als der gesamten Verkehr
inklusiv habe ich alles ausdiskutiert
ähm ich habe mal alles machen wir können
auch darüber sprechen was fliegen
auslöst also ich fliege schon eine Weile
nicht mehr vielleicht die ja mehr beide
aus verschiedenen Gründen
seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr in den USA ich
bin seit 2013
ich vermute jetzt nur aber der Punkt auf
den ich hinaus will ist das was sie für
richtig halten was sie für richtig
halten das betrifft doch bestimmt eine
Reihe von Leute Sachen ich halte das
auch für euch richtig dann gibt's eine
ganze Reihe von Leuten ich würde mal
sagen gefühlt die Mehrheit sowohl global
als auch hier in Deutschland die das
nicht so eindeutig beantwortet wie sie
sich beide das beantworten was machen
wir jetzt und jetzt wird es jetzt
befohlen müssen dann alle über diese
Woche springen oder wie läuft das dann
völlig anders du verpasst vielleicht ein
bisschen Neues über die Entwicklung
USA alle Länder wo halt an der
Stammzelle etwas freizüge geforscht
werden da weiß in Deutschland das
Fleisch das habe ich schon gehört ist in
USA zugelassen
Israel das wird sich aus rein
ökonomischen Gründen
haben entschuldigung aber
einfach nur sagen dass wenn man heute
mit Forschern redet auch gerade
nahrungsmittelexperten das Fleisch wird
zunehmend aus der Stammzelle aus der
Petrischale kommen ich habe zwar nicht
weil es besser schmeckt oder aus ethisch
moralischen weil die armen Tiere schon
werden einfach aus rein ökonomischen
Gründen Transportwege Futter Soja
Regenwald Vernichtung das wird zunehmend
in einem irren Tempo in der Stammzelle
gezüchtet und die ersten Unternehmen USA
machen ist längst ist es ja schon
zugelassen einzige Bundesland das ist
die Zukunft ob es euch gefällt oder
nicht ich bin da nicht dafür aber das
ist ein Fakt bedeutet
in Deutschland jetzt bleiben dann
einfach Menschen gibt sie der erste
Fleisch einfach nicht mehr zugenommen
Holland von einem Professor Post hat 250
000 $ in der Winkel kostet so wir sind
jetzt sind wir bei 25 $ genau zehn Jahre
später ins Rechner 10 Jahre weiter
irgendwann wird die Stammzelle so
günstig das ist natürlich billiger wird
als es reale Fleisch und dann ist diese
Frage ob das dann nur noch für die Urban
Eliten die er mir sogar eine bestimmte
hat sich damit erübrigt ja das muss man
aber auch erstmal essen wollen also ich
würde sowas nicht essen ich esse lieber
das Stück und das Steak was ich gerade
noch irgendwo beim Landwirt gesehen habe
bei uns werden wir auch noch den
einzigen Fleischer weil das ja auch
alles wechseln sind zu fasziniert worden
ist der schieß das Stück noch auf der
Wiese da gibt's keine Stresshormone
nicht das ist alles wunderbar und ähm
und ich glaube einfach nicht und das was
sie vorhin gesagt haben ähm wir müssen
eine besondere Haltung haben ja wie
Demeter oder andere Betriebe und und das
wird auch noch viel viel teurer wird
sich das noch erlauben werden
entschuldigungsmittel aber das ist ja
das was vorher noch gerade gesagt hat
wenn Sie wenn Sie die Leute befragen
sind sie alle auf Bio 80 % wollen gerne
Bio Fleisch haben wenn sie aber den
Laden wieder rauskommt dann sehen Sie
was ist denn im Kopf drin nicht mal 20
%.
ja nicht den Preis was ist Umwelt und
Menschen Schaden verursacht mit
inkludiert haben ein Problem mit ihrer
Kunst runter Leute hin und kaufen
weniger SO3
Weg subventioniert wir sind es völlig
einig die Subvention läuft völlig falsch
wir suchten Turnieren giftige
konventionelle ungesunde schlecht
produzierte Lebensmittel und die gut
produzierten also bio ist zu teuer das
geht natürlich auch auf Kosten des
Gesundheitswesen sie schlechte wir essen
desto mehr Krankheit in der Tat das
müsste genau umgekehrt laufen wir müssen
ja hochwertige Lebensmittel
subventionieren und anständige
Tierhaltung Freilandhaltung und von mir
aus auch gerne jagdpunkte das ist
wirklich Bio Fleisch und dafür die
giftigen Lebens mussten CO2-Preis
bekommen sobald Produkten CO2-Preis
haben ob sie T-Shirt ist eine Flugreise
und ein Stück Fleisch ist das Problem
gelöst